today we have a new world poker champion  damien salas won the world series of  poker's main event last night over at  the rio here he is  he's the first argentinian to win the  ten thousand dollar buy-in  texas holdem tournament it was postponed  from may of last year because of the  pandemic  so players started online fought their  way to one u.s  and one international final table before  last night's heads up event  salus walked away with 2.55 million  dollars  well the money isn't too bad from either  he did outdual u.s champ joseph herbert  who took home a little more than one and  a half  million dollars so congrats to both of  them